[Musique]
bonsoir et heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 78 le journal voici les
titres l'osos des élus 5 qutino a été
entendu l'Assemblée nationale a entériné
les nouvelles règles de calcul qui
devaient amputer le budget de l'l option
de 13 à 16 millions d'euros la
sensérienne Charline Conan nommée 2e
dauphine de Miss elegance France le
weekend dernier elle revient sur cette
élection qui s'est déroulé à forge les
EAU en scène
maritime dans ce journal 14 février fête
des amoureux un incontournable comme
chaque année les sites de restauration
et hôtellerie en profitent eux aussi et
sont nombreux à jouer le jeu et à
proposer des offres
spéciales c'était il y a une semaine les
ex Villenouvelle crié à à l'injustice
fiscale les élus voyaient déjà le budget
de l'agglomération amputé de 13 à 16
millions d'euros aujourd'hui nos élus
sont soulagés l'Assemblée nationale a
enterré cette idée jeudi dernier une
bouffée d'air pour le président de 50
ans en Yveline Michel
logier il était anormal que on ne prenne
pas en
considération notre origine historique
c'est-à-dire nous sommes issus d'une
ville nouvelle et donc à ce titre-là
nous avons construit énormément
d'équipements publics ce qui fait que
notre communauté d'agglomération
aujourd'hui a une lourde dette mais
dette qui a été bien sûr généré par tous
ces aménagements donc si nous
bénéficions depuis quelques années de
cette situation il était anormal que à
l'occasion du vote de la loi de finance
un amendement soit voté en catimini euh
juste avant Noël c'était l'interview du
président de sa an iveline Michel logier
et du côté des élus de gauche de C50 an
en iveline il se félicite aussi de ce
changement pour la première secrétaire
fédérale du Parti socialiste Yveline
Sandrine grandambe les interpellations
de Benoît amont député des Yveline et
des quatre maires de gauche de
l'agglomération ont permis d'accélérer
le
dossier samedi dernier Benoît amont a
dévoilé son équipe de campagne on
retrouve l'ancienne ministre de la
Culture Aurélie phipti des proches de
Martin Aubri ou encore l'économiste
Thomas picketti Trapp est aussi présent
dans l' dans l'organigramme à l'image
d'Ali Rabet au poste de chef de
cabinet donc mon rôle c'est d'être à
l'interface entre le candidat et la
classe politique et la société civile
j'organise ces déplacements ces
rendez-vous c'est les sollicitation dont
il fait l'objet qui sont évidemment très
nombreuses lors d'une campagne
présidentielle donc mon rôle à moi c'est
de faire en sorte que la machine
fonctionne et que la vie quotidienne du
candidat soit rythmée efficace et
productive l'objectif de la campagne de
la candidature de Benoît amont ce sera
de porter les thématiques qui ont fait
son succès à la primaire qui lui ont
permis de remporter à près de 60 % les
primaires de la gauche avec 2 millions
d'électeurs qui se sont mobilisés donc
les recettes gagnantes de la primaire
seront utilisées et renforcées pour
présenter un programme cohérent solide
structuré à 50 ans en Eveline
l'événement bubble Sky se poursuit dans
dans les méiathèques des animations sont
organisées autour de la bande dessinée
depuis le mois de janvier faisons un
point sur l'un de ces moments d'échange
qui s'est déroulé le weekend dernier le
café comics êtes-vous plutôt BD
franco-belge manga ou comics des styles
littéraires différents qui alimentent
les discussions entre lecteurs et
bibliothécaire notamment lors de ce café
comics organisé à la Médiathèque
jean-rousselot de guillancour des
moments d'échange pour découvrir de
nouveaux ouvrages je me sens peut-être
plus plus à l'aise avec le format de la
BD j'avoue que le manga je n suis pas je
ne suis pas vraiment très spécialiste de
manga je regarde je regarde je je me
balade aussi dans les rayons mangas mais
j'avoue que je suis un petit peu moins
attiré par immédiatement attiré par le
manga que par la BD je lis pas mal de BD
mais plus spécifiquement manga donc
c'est plus ce ce style là qui qui moi
m'tire personnellement alors manga très
peu j'en ai lu qu'un j'ai lu des S notes
il paraît que c'est quand même voilà
fondamental mais mais sinon je dis un
peu de BD un peu de comics ouais mais
pas énormément plusieurs comi BD et
manga sont présentés aux lecteurs des
livres envoyés par les librairies aux
médiathèqu pour les faire découvrir aux
adhérents et recueillir leur avis un
public assez ouvert concernant le monde
de la BD et ben en fait on a un public
assez éclectique donc du coup on a des
fans de mangas des fans de comics un peu
de fans de BD puis après on a des gens
qui aiment un petit peu tout qui sont
suffisamment curieux pour tapé dans les
trois domaines un clivage qui tend à
s'effacer plusieurs dessinateurs ont
déjà conjugué les trois styles dans
plusieurs ouvrages laabattage des arbres
nécessaires à la réalisation du tram 13
Express a démarré la semaine dernière à
proximité du château de Saint-Germain en
l'air celle-ci comprend la création
d'une liaison entre le RA de
Saint-Germain en lait à c de saint-cir
rerc soit 19 km de voie 12 stations
desservies pour un trajet de 30
minutes au début début du mois nous vous
présentions Charline Conan une jeune
sincyrienne élu Miss élégance
île-de-fance en octobre dernier et bien
le weekend dernier elle a eu a eu lieu
le la finale de la compétition à forg
les EAU en scène maritime et la miss est
arrivée 2e
dauphine j'étais très étonné je
m'attendais pas à être dans les C
finalistes déjà déjà dans les 10 dans un
premier temps et puis ensuite dans les 5
et bon une fois que j'étais dans dans
les 5 c'était que du bonheur donc voilà
en plus dans le top 3 génial je suis
très très heureuse j'ai fa des bons
souvenirs c'était pas évident tous les
jours par contre c'est vrai mais bon le
le résultat est est positif et puis bon
bah ça me manque déjà donc c'est que
c'était bien les ballons de B les
ballons de basket ont laissé leur place
au pas de danse au St au stade
montboreau de Versailles je vais y
arriver c'était le premier Grand Prix de
Versailles une compétition de danse
latine et standard le public a pu
découvrir
salsa Val ou encore tango retour sur la
compétition avec des images de Nicolas
[Musique]
dendr 10 minutes de danse latine pour
gagner des points Juliette et Raphaël
viennent de maison la fite et évolue
ensemble depuis un an et
demi on est entre loisir et le niveau
ouais disons qu'on n'est pas on est sur
le début de ce qu'on peut considérer
comme la compétition en Nationale oui
euh sérieuse on va dire h on en fait
suffisamment pour que ce soit plus du
loisir mais pas suffisamment pour dire
que c'est du haut niveau et qu'on passe
notre vie à ça c'est pas du temps plein
on a nos études à côté il participe au
premier Grand Prix de Versailles si
niveau de 8 à 70 ans certains
compétiteurs s'entraînent une dizaine
d'heures par semaine
ça nous permet de maintenir notre forme
olympique c'est un excellent sport la
danse c'est complet le corps le
mental plutôt que d'aller entre la télé
et le fauteuil vaut mieux faire un peu
de la danse une compétition dite
classificatrice où se mê danse
latin-américaine et danse standard de la
Vals du quickstep plus de 12 heur de
compétition observé par C juges on juge
avec la technique avec la musique avec
musicalité avec les lignes de corps les
le travail des pieds la l'harmonie du
couple la présentation du couple la
chorégraphie si elle est bien dans les
dans les racines des danses c'est un
rendez-vous important de la saison
toutes les semaine il y a des
compétitions classificatrices et il leur
faut faire au moins six compétitions
classificatrices afin de passer dans la
série supérieure une centaine de couples
s'est affronter ce weekend prochaine
compétition pour ses danseurs le 25
février à Beaumont suroise
restons dans la thématique loisir avec
cette activité très tendance des escape
game ils ont lieu en ce moment à la
Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet un
moment de plaisir pour les petits et
pour les
grands dans un escape game tout commence
par une énigme j'ai besoin de votre aide
pour essayer de trouver ce mouton qui a
manger tout le gra et c'est parti pour
un bon quart d'heure à se creuser les
ménages enfin dans C es équipes ce sont
plutôt les parents qui cherchent donc
c'est vous qui vous amusez ou c'est les
enfants
je pense qu'il y a les deux les parents
les parents aiment bien et les enfants
aiment beaucoup ouais c'est la première
fois que la Bergerie Nationale de
Rambouillet organise ses escape games
une façon ludique de faire découvrir au
petit le monde de la ferme on veut
montrer aux enfants les différents
métiers de la ferme mais on l'a fait
d'une forme assez originale c'est qu'on
les a fait sous forme d'énigme le fait
de ses activités c'est le jeu leur
transmettre des valeurs et des
informations sur
l'agriculture derrière le jeu une autre
magie prend vite le dessus la rencontre
avec l'animal moutons vaches et cochons
ne manqu pas d'attendrir les jeunes
visiteurs qu'est-ce que tu a les
bergeries caresser les
moutons caresser les vaches caresser les
animaux quoi la première semaine de
vacances le succès était au rendez-vous
la bergerie attend quelques centaines de
visiteurs sur les de semaines apprentis
fermier c'est à vous de
jouer une affiche de gala ce weekend en
sport une rencontre entre les sapeurs
pompiers et les fédérations sportives de
la police nationale s'est déroulé ce
samedi après-midi au stade de plaisir au
programme des matchs de rugby féminin et
masculin les recettes de cette rencontre
ont été reversées à des occasions on
écoute la DTN de la police Francis
casttin c'est de organismes donc police
et et ODP qui sont de deux organismes
qui qui œuvrent toute l'année au
quotidien pour que les enfants qui se
retrouve orphelin ne soit pas laissé
seul et et donc il y a cet esprit de
solidarité qui est vraiment très fort
que ce soit au niveau policiers ou au
niveau des pompiers donc là on le
retrouve aujourd'hui aussi puisque
lorsqu'on a été sollicité pour organiser
cet événement on a de suite dit oui quoi
voilà on n pas cherché à savoir combien
ça allait coûtter tout ce qui s'en suit
voilà nous ce qui nous intéressait Ctait
vraiment V ce moment de solidarité et
pouvoir faire partager ces moments là
quoi et demain c'est la fête des
amoureux un incontournable comme chaque
année les sites de restauration et
hôtellerie en profitent eux aussi ils
sont nombreux à jouer le jeu et à
proposer des offres spéciales pour fêter
la Saint-Valentin nous vous avons
réservé quelques
idées ici les cuisiniers préparent leurs
ustensiles comme Cupidon prépare ses
flèches tous les ans ce restaurant de
morpa célèbre la fête des amoureux
autour d'un repas spécial cette année
sera un duo terre et m on a voulu
d'abord principalement rester dans le
thème rouge de la Saint-Valentin donc
nous sommes partis sur en entrée une
déclinaison de moelle de betterave et
son carpacho de thon mariné à la sauce
ponzou et pour le plat ça nous a permis
on a fait un duo ardent de terre et M
donc pour plaire à l'homme et pour
plaire aussi à la femme avec le poisson
et pour l'homme le magré de canard la
soirée Saint-Valentin c'est une soirée
agréable c'est une soirée de couple
principalement avec une ambiance on va
dire peut-être un peu plus romantique je
crois que c'est pour tout le monde aussi
bien jeune moins jeune que plus ancien
on va dire il a il y a vraiment pas
d'âge pour la Saint-Valentin pour
terminer le repas un élixir du désir
composé de gingembre canelle et safran
mariné dans un vieux Rome compter 58 €
le menu par personne la soirée peut se
poursuivre dans un lieu atypique les
yourts de l'île de loisir offrent un
cadre intime et des paysans desourts il
y en a C il y a uneour qui fait 66 m²
qui est consacré un espace cuisine donc
complètement équipé et quatre ytes qui
servent de couchage donc deux yourourts
de et deux yourourtes de 2 c'est chauffé
c'est tranquille et ça permet je pense
de passer un petit séjour romantique
agréable et original pour passer la nuit
à la manière mongole prévoyz 60 € la
Saint-Valentin a une tradition toujours
qualifié de romantique par 69 % des
Français selon un sondage odoxa
l'occasion de raviver la flamme de
l'amour c'est la fin de ce 78 le journal
bonne soirée à
[Musique]
tous